el sistema electoral de hong kong aunque
alejado de los estándares occidentales
era bastante más democrático que el que
habían dejado los británicos y permitía
la disensión política eso va a ser
bastante más complicado a partir de
ahora al parlamento pasa de 70 a 90
asientos y solo 20 serán de elección
directa además el comité electoral podrá
medir el patriotismo de los candidatos y
rechazar a los que juzgue tibios pekín
considera la reforma como indispensable
porque el bando opositor antes de las
elecciones del pasado año que fueron
finalmente suspendidas por el
coronavirus había anunciado que votaría
en contra de todas las acciones de
gobierno para forzar su bloqueo así que
pekín ha querido eliminar ese riesgo de
todas formas las próximas elecciones
parecen ahora una inquietud menor para
los políticos opositores una cincuentena
de ellos se enfrentan a largas penas de
prisión después de haber sido detenidos
en aplicación de la nueva ley de
seguridad nacional aprobada el año
pasado tanto esa ley como la reforma
electoral son la respuesta excepcional
de pekín a unos problemas también
excepcionales como fueron
protestas violentas que durante un año
subieron en el caos a hong kong